how's your Wednesday going mine's good
this is me doing everyday cosplay as
pebbles from Flintstones just like truly
truly stunted by and in measurable
amount of daddy issues bamm-bamm hi my
name is grace Helbig if you don't know
now you know your life is different now
I went on my Twitter at grace Helbig and
I asked you guys what kind of video did
you want to see today and a lot of you
said you just wanted to see an uplifting
video that had nothing to do with the
state of the world or politics or
anything and so I thought what is
happening outside of politics that is
interesting to people
the mannequin challenge Barack Obama I'm
pretty sure was the one that started
this challenge someone asked him about a
year ago what if Donald Trump became
president and he just went
everyone has done this I am late to this
challenge so I decided why don't I and
my dog goose try to do the mannequin
challenge here's how it worked out for
us share with me anything
Oh your tongue shakers cut of your
tongue damn it oh you late mother for
sure oh damn it did you just that's not
how this junker is we're gonna pretend
to be Anakin's Internet that's
interesting I know it is kind of boring
this is you protesting the American
challenge there's nothing in that bowl
but just metal so you'd rather just lick
straight-up metal for over two solid
minutes then participate in the
mannequin challenge yeah you speak for a
lot of us oh it's just my fault that was
my fault does my fault doesn't I thought
that was my fault I kicked a bone it
kicked about I can hear you moving
just broke it just completely broken
here's what I've learned one it's the
dumbest [ __ ] thing ever - there's a
reason it's called a challenge some of
us do not succeed some of us struggle
who cares I hope you guys enjoyed this
video at all if you did give it a thumbs
up and hit this button right here and
subscribe to my youtube channel because
it doesn't get different than this
I hope this took your mind off of
anything that was troubling you over the
last few moments of time and that's it I
don't know
so here's how the challenge works we
pretend the perfect mannequins
you don't want a mannequin is I'm glad
you asked okay
imagine do you actually know so we're
going to pretend our mannequins why
because it's what I don't [ __ ] know
is what people will [ __ ] see